today we do not want to get any new C++
users we hope that you will all use Java
or Kotlin if you can but obviously there
are people who can't them we're here for
you and so I think what we really want
to say is just we aren't working on C
and C++ we do care we're trying to make
things better and we want to talk about
some of the things that we've been doing
over the past few years so specifically
we are the the platform the OS C++ team
and we took over the NDK around 2015 for
our 10 the the parts that we consider
the NDK are basically the compiler the
headers on the libraries so we're not
talking about things like the studio
integration the Gradle stuff that's the
studio folks are around they've got
numerous talks and you can you can talk
to them other times so Dan's gonna start
with a introduction to what we've done
since we took over the NDK yes so like
Elliott said we took over in about May
2015 that was NDK our 10e at the time so
I'm going to be covering from then on to
give some perspective with the OS C++
experience looked like back then this
was marshmallow we were mostly way done
with that we had the transition to clang
well underway at that point we moved a
device in its entirety we were working
on others we had complete C++ 14 support
from Lib C++ at that point Google is big
on dogfooding so the idea being you know
we should be using what you're using so
that we find the bugs before we ship
them to you unfortunately for the NDK at
the time this is what things look like
we had four different compilers that was
two versions of GCC two versions of
clang clang was heavily forked three
different C++ libraries we had STL port
hadn't received updates upstream in
years so it was still in C++ oh three we
had good new STL more commonly known as
get new his lips did C++ that's what you
have on your normal Linux system and Lib
C++ which is all vm's
C++ standard library which we were using
in the platform this was also quite
heavily forked in the NDK and it had a
compatibility library that let it run
going back to Gingerbread and that
library had quite a few bugs
unfortunately so that was a major source
of issues we also had a copy of the OS
headers for every single API level and
architecture and typically that meant
that if we fix a bug in the headers we
only fix it in the most recent version
and it didn't get back ported which was
a big problem because you were using
whichever version of the headers Master
min SDK version so if we only fix the
latest version you wouldn't actually see
the fix for about five years maybe more
so the question is how do we get to this
dogfooding world and we could
essentially either just stop shipping in
decays for a couple years while we dealt
with all of the issues that had to get
us there that didn't sound particularly
appealing so instead we tried to do this
in smaller less disruptive steps each
step still had some disruption but was a
much easier hurdle to get over we did
this in a predictable opt-in opt-out and
then removed cycle if I use the unified
headers as an example
r14 we added a flag to turn those on our
15 if your app wasn't ready to switch
yet you could still opt out with a
different flag and then by our 16 we'd
worked out all the kinks and we were
ready to move on so we removed the
previous option the compilers we started
with this really with our 11 that was
when we unfort the NDK is clang and that
alone let us close just a ton of bugs it
was then the same compiler that we used
to build the OS R 13 couple releases
later we switched that to be the default
and then by R 18 it was we were to the
point that we could actually rely
bullion clang and Lib C++ so we removed
GCC at this point all of Android all of
Chrome OS iOS all of these are using
clang so if you are targeting a subset
of these operating systems your code is
much more likely to be portable between
them the unified headers I mentioned
earlier this is the gist of what those
look like instead of having a different
copy of this header for every single API
letter level we have this annotation
here introduced in that says that dlv
sim was
available until Android 24 the compiler
will make sure that you can't actually
build against that if your min SDK
version is not at least 24 we still have
all of the types the macros the
constants all the things that you need
to use these api is visible so if you
are running if your ministy k version is
lower than the device you're actually
running on you can still access the new
api with deal sim and use all the
correct types rather than copy pasting
all the types and constants into your
project like you would have to with the
previous solution this did done earth a
handful of bugs
it was mostly actually old Android
workarounds that had been checked in had
to be deleted in order to work with the
new option but bleeding codes pretty
straightforward so that's that's not too
bad
Lib C++ like I said this was one of the
more this was really our main goal was
to give you a up-to-date C++ standard
library something that actually could
support C++ 11 at the time and then 14
and now even 17 it was a fairly wrong
long road to get there it required those
previous fixes first in our 16 was when
we really started doing this on earnest
we rewrote that compatibility library
with all the bugs added a whole bunch of
tests made sure that that was nice and
solid and we shipped that in our 16 took
the beta sticker off and said yes please
start using this it wasn't the default
yet we waited for our 17 for that so our
17 it became the default and then our 18
everything was looking good and we
removed the other options
so as of our 18 and the NDK had a single
compiler the same one we used to build
the OS a single set of headers same ones
we used to build the OS and a single C++
library at the same one we used to build
the operating system so that was
dogfooding mission accomplished
[Applause]
does this mean that there's no more
disruption when you update your ndk
unfortunately not quite
there's still a few changes we are gonna
need to be making this is particularly
to reduce the size of the NDK there's a
whole bunch of redundant copies of
things right now and if your build
system is currently relying on those
redundant copies when I go to delete
them your build system is gonna break
fortunately as long as you're on NDK our
19 or newer NDK build and C make are -
officially supported options are already
on to this so as long as you're using
those you're already covered if you do
have your own build system there's
fortunately a doc linked down there at
the bottom that will tell you all you
need to know to actually integrate this
into your own build system aside from
that we do have the two build system
still and UK build is alive and well
it is purpose-built for Android so often
if you are targeting only Android that
is actually going to be your easiest
option that is not the normal case you
are probably also talk targeting iOS
windows handful of other platforms in
that case see make is your best bet is
gonna be the easiest option for
cross-platform work and with that I'm
handing off to Elliot for debugging all
right so I think it's not really gonna
be much of a surprise but the first
thing to talk about with C C++ debugging
is memory issues so like I said at the
start we we have the OS C++ team so any
kind of problem that you guys are having
in apps we've been having in the RS
itself for a long time typically we've
used a SAN for this we've this is a new
hardware accelerated a SAN and hopefully
we'll talk about that some other time
but right now Isan is kind of the state
of the art for this it's what we're
using for the platform and what we're
going to talk about today is how you can
use this in the NDK it is supported in
the NDK it's just perhaps less well
known so these are the kind of issues
that a Tsang can find it's basically
everything except for leaks for leaks we
use now at debug you can find
documentation for that on
developer.android.com/design the same
place as the ACE and I can't
but the key thing I want to talk about
is this rap dat Sh so a semi Android is
interesting in that you the way it works
is that you have this LD preload this
shared library that has to get loaded
before your code starts basically it
intercepts all of the memory allocation
and freeing operations and to do that it
obviously needs to be running before any
allocations are actually made normally
this wouldn't be a problem but on
Android when your app starts you're not
actually starting from scratch you're
starting from a clone of the zygote
which you know it's it's generally
helpful if you know it reduces your app
startup time greatly because the kind of
common startup that every upward have to
do with all the framework stuff has
already happened if you want more
details about this like out the art
folks are going to begin a talk tomorrow
morning where they'll be talking about
some of the new optimizations they've
done to that in queue but for our
purposes all you need to know is this
kind of gets in your way for ASAP so
what we added was a thing where if you
have a shell script in your apk called
wrap dot SH and in the correct directory
when we come to launch when the zygote
comes to launch your app instead of four
instead of cloning what's already there
it actually starts completely from
scratch so here's an example of what
such as shell script could look like
so dollar commercial at is basically
shell for all the arguments so what's
happening here is when we when this when
Android calls your app daughter's age it
gives you the exact command line that it
would otherwise have have run so here
we're just saying do what you would have
done anyway so the only difference is
you're in a completely fresh process
you're not clone from the zygote and
anything that you output to standard
output or standard error will go to the
log it'll go to logcat rather than just
being lost like it normally would again
because the assumption is you're
debugging here you want to see anything
so here's a slightly more interesting
version then this is saying so the a-sun
options there's a link a couple of
slides ago
for all the details about the different
Asian options this is just an example of
like here are common options that you
will want if you're using a Sun on
Android so that puts that into the
environment for when your app starts LD
preload like I said that that's a clue
to the dynamic linker when you start
this this app load this library first
and this is this is kind of the runtime
for it for a SAM NDK build knows about
this it'll do this magic for you there's
a little wrinkle with Studio at the
moment that we need to teach studio to
actually package this if you're not
using studio you don't really need to
anything if you do if you are definitely
go to developer.android.com/design
and we've got an example there that has
some screenshots of what you need to do
if you're using nd cable this is more
what it looks like in your Android or MK
file you literally just tell the
compiler please turn on address
sanitization the no Amit frame pointer
thing is so that you we can give you
good quick unwinds like I say if you do
this NDK build picks up on that it's
spots that you've said sanitized address
and it'll actually set up the right
dosage for you so like it's a lots more
documentation on that it is kind of
complicated but once you get the hang of
it it's it's it's not too bad there's
documentation about that on
developer.android.com/design the
platform has used this for since 2012 we
use this for a long time now but by
default NDK users aren't getting this if
you want us to catch easy sort of buffer
overrun bugs
if you define fortify source 2 2 again
you can look this up on the web for
details you define fortify source you
can actually have us behind the scenes
we will the compiler if it can do so
we'll prove at compile time that your
code is either correct or incorrect it
is incorrect it'll just spew out an
error and you can fix it there and then
if you can't prove it it'll actually
insert a call to a slightly different
routine that will do some runtime
checking so in this example this is
something
obviously very contrived but this is
something that the sort of static
analysis built into the compiler doesn't
actually spot it doesn't realize that
that 32 is going to be used as that
parameter to read so it turns us into a
runtime check and if that fails you then
get a nice clear abort and the abort
message will be along the line so if you
know fortify the specific function you
called and then what what you asked it
to do and what it thinks that the
current state of the world is similar to
that and even easier case we have a lot
of sort of app compat issues where you
know SELinux policies have changed or
permissions on some file have changed or
even the existence of a file has changed
but apps are assuming oh I just open
this file then I read from it and they
kind of plow on without actually
checking for errors so it's simple cases
like that where it's it's never valid to
give a null file pointer to any other
studio function so we will actually just
on recent builds we'll just blow you out
of the water
nice cleanable nice clean error message
another similar thing on on more recent
builds is that there's there's been a
lot of confusion about P thread T which
is what you get from pthread create and
you use with all the other P thread
functions and pip T which is basically
just the integer that the kernel users
for it's it's raw thread and you do
sometimes need to deal with both of
these depending on what your your app is
doing you can get a pity from a P thread
T there's a P thread getted NP function
that you can call so if you're using
some kind of low-level linux api that
requires a tid you can do that what you
can't do is you can't give a tid you
know a PID to one of the P thread
functions historically it would just
silently do nothing because it would
look on its list of current thread say
I've not heard of that that's not a
thread and do nothing
nowadays it actually catches this again
nice clear abort and tells you what
you've done usually this means if it's a
low number like this it means that
you've made this P thread and untipped
confusion if it's a high number that
means you've lost track of one of your
threads it's it's basically the thread
equivalent of like a double close or an
valid free those are often a bit harder
to debug something brand-new and cue
that that's new to Android is FD cents
so file descriptors it's what's behind
the scenes of like the studio file or
the other C++ file API is it's it's an
integer it's what the the Linux kernel
uses to represent an open file and it's
quite easy to to mess up the the
ownership of these and what's really
unfortunate is that the kernel does a
kind of first fit allocation so if you
allocate five files and then you close
one and open another you'll get that
same number reused so it's really hard
to debug these so what we've done we've
actually added tracking for this to the
C library the link at the bottom
explains how if you've got sort of
higher level classes that that control
some resources that have file
descriptors you can actually take part
in this but we've wired up the basic
classes the basics trucks things like
file instead i/o so that you you know
this example on the slide for example
this is a real bug that we actually had
in Android that was found by this
obviously the real one was spread over
multiple files and hundreds of lines but
it boils down to this that now is a nice
clear abort well there's actually two
modes again see the documentation you
can either but by default at the moment
it just logs if it finds an issue and
then lets you carry on so it preserves
that kind of backward buggy behavior
hopefully in future will actually make
that fully enforcing but you can do that
yourself in the meantime so unwinding
this is whenever you have a crash you've
seen the sort of stacks that you get
from that this is you know behind the
scenes as a piece of code called the
unwinder which is basically just
crawling up your stack working out what
called what in the past that really it
worked fine for sins he plus plus but it
kind of fell apart when it hit Java so
one thing we've done more recently we've
we've written a completely new online
der and the major feature of that is
that it actually understands Java and
Kotlin frames it doesn't matter whether
they're ahead of time compile jittered
or interpreted it'll do the right thing
in queue we've added a few extra
little tricks elf build IDs are useful
every every object file every executable
you have has a has a hash encoded in it
will actually show those hashes in queue
so that you can if you sometimes you're
not sure like is this is this really the
were they running the right version of
the code I think they were running on my
debugging against the wrong thing you
can you can check that out so here's an
example of what the stacks used to look
like you know the blue parts the C++
that that used to work fine but as soon
as we'd hit Java we'd basically stop
because the way Java the way the art
runtime maintains its stack is very
different in P and Q we've actually
taught it about that so this is the kind
of stack you'll get these days it
doesn't even matter whether it's
interpreted or jittered we'll just do
the right thing we even have if you have
your own JIT we actually use the same
kind of API behind the scenes but the
things like gdb use for this so you can
actually tell us about your own jets as
well what can you do when you have a
good online der profiling is an obvious
thing that comes to mind in NDK r-13 we
shipped a thing called simple perf this
is basically like the Linux perf tool
it's a command-line tool you can use
it's useful and it was certainly useful
for the OS people not so useful for app
developers because you can't generally
you know run your app whenever you want
so one thing that we did as a sort of
stopgap was we added a a tool to give
you sort of HTML flame graphs that you
could then see in the browser but
obviously the real aim was the GUI
profiler hopefully you saw that the this
was released in studio three you want it
was mentioned in the studio blogpost and
hopefully you've tried that if you
haven't that might actually be worth
switching to studio so you can try that
so this is what the command line looks
like basically the same if anyone's
familiar with the linkspurr tool it's
basically the same there's these
separate record record and report steps
we also support annotation if you
actually want to see you know right down
to the assembler level where was my code
you can't connect to existing processes
but
again the easiest way to do that is just
use studios the studio UI is the picture
in the foreground picture in the
background is the sort of HTML thing we
have so now we will talk about some of
the things that people hit either when
switching to you know from GCC to clan
or from new STL to Lib C++ or just in
fact in terms of upgrading between
different versions of the NDK so this
was a very common issue we saw when
people were updating to the unified
headers you would update and something
your code would no longer compile
because some function that really ought
to be there was missing really common
case for this was M map just disappeared
the reason for this was that Bionic
supports this feature called file offset
bits it allows you to specify that you
want a 64 bit off T so you can deal with
files larger than two gigabytes this was
a feature that wasn't in older n decays
so if you set file offset bits when you
were using an older NDK nothing happened
it's failed silently you got no
indication that nothing happened and it
moved on when you then upgraded you were
getting this feature and if you asked
for it before it was actually available
your build would fail
fortunately the fix for this is
extremely easy if all you want is the
old behavior back grep through your
project find the line that says file
offset bits it'll be in either one of
your build scripts or possibly in one of
your source files just delete that line
everything will be back to the way it
was if you do need a large file support
the answer is a bit more complicated
essentially you need to figure out what
your ministy K version is what you're
okay with your min SDK version being
which subsets the API is you need
fortunate this is really well documented
the dock length there you can search on
our bug tracker if you have more
questions just file a bug we're happy to
help so I think probably everyone who
has native code has seen this you know
you you run your new version of your apk
you get an unsatisfied linker we had
this ourselves on the platform so we
have debugging information in there
if you set this property you don't need
a rooted device for this debug
properties you can set
regardless you can actually turn on the
full login from the from the dynamic
linker itself it'll tell you everything
every file it considers and they'll tell
you why it didn't open it so rather than
just kind of this short DL error message
that you get in the unsatisfied link
error if you really want to see the full
information you can here no example of
this because it is just far too verbose
another common issue you'll run into
particularly while updating to a new
compiler or switching switching between
different types of compilers or even
just to a new version of the compiler is
undefined behavior C++ is full of
undefined behavior it's very exciting
this can just lead to all sorts of
surprising behaviors in your application
so fortunately clang gives you a really
good tool to try to sort out these
issues it's undefined behavior sanitizer
like with a SAN you can enable this
quite simply in your android make if you
add these flags instead of just
unpredictable behavior at runtime you
will get a nice stack trace and a crash
in logcat that explains what went wrong
and where it went wrong this is also
extremely useful for a security
conscious code it is much better to just
stop and restart rather than continue
into unpredictable behavior for security
reasons we actually ship with this on in
the platform for some modules things
like stage fright for example back in
Nellore m whenever that was undefined
behavior sanitizer was the only tool we
had that could actually catch that bug
and so we now keep that on as a
mitigation right so one thing that also
caused trouble for people who was
switching from GCC to clang is the clang
is a lot fuzzier about assembler this
example there are four different
instructions so that might be it's
probably obvious to a human which one
that they meant but client refuses to
guess GCC would just guess the
workaround if you if you don't have time
to to work on this right now and you
just want to
get on with your life after no
integrated AAS that lets you use the
binutils assembler behind the scenes so
you'll get the existing behavior we
actually move forward and fixed all of
the ambiguities in our code the easy
trick for doing that is just use option
another common problem you will go and
update your SDK it will update the NDK
with it and now your build is broken
because your Gradle plug-in didn't
upgrade there are a handful of
assumptions that the Gradle plug-in will
make about how old the NDK is structured
we are doing everything we can to remove
those where possible but fortunately
there's another really easy fix for this
problem out in beta earlier today with
Studio 3/5 you can actually specify your
NDK version in your build.gradle right
alongside your Gradle plugin version
that way these two things remain in
lockstep you upgrade them at the same
time everything will be fine again that
is Gradle 3.5 plug-in so you will need
that first but from then on you're
covered this also lets you install
multiple versions with a NDK easily so
if you are working on multiple projects
and you need different versions of the
NDK for each one because the project
started at different times that's now
nice and easy to do so hopefully you
already read the blog posts that we've
had over the past couple of years about
the move to 64-bit and the requirement
that everybody supports it the main
thing we want to talk to you about today
is just some tips so we had this problem
back in lollipop like my team we
basically spent the entire year fixing
all the code all these 32-bit
assumptions for those of you who are
already running the same code on iOS you
shouldn't have a problem you've already
been through this transition for those
of you aren't the main thing that that
caused trouble for us was J&I code so
places where you have a Java class that
has some kind of native peer that was
all using Jayant for us so we had to go
through and catch all of those these
warnings and this actually turns these
warnings on and then makes some errors
this was completely necessary for us to
fix the platform
these catch places where you're
converting a 32 bit int to and from a
pointer a trickier one a less obvious
one is implicit function declarations
will hurt you as well because the the
old K and our assumption is that if you
don't tell the compiler what the type of
a function is the assumption is that it
returns int which means 32 bits which
means it'll truncate your pointer so in
this example foo actually returns a char
star we didn't tell the compiler that we
ignored its warning about the implicit
function declaration and it said fine
I'll just drop those top 32 bits and
obviously that doesn't go well at run
time so that's the that's the thing to
add to your build if you actually want
it the compiler to just say no this is
wrong I'm not going to do that so dance
now I'm going to talk about some of the
things that we're working on for the
near future yes so somewhat short term
on the roadmap we are looking into a new
linker right now we have B FD and we
have gold we are looking at all D for
the NDK we are already using LD for the
platform it for one is a lot faster for
something like linking the Linux kernel
it is actually twice as fast so instead
of a three-minute link step it is only a
minute and a half it is also a lot
better at detecting ODR violations and
reporting them in useful ways if you've
ever tried to debug one of those with
one of the other linkers it can be quite
a pain it's also got better support for
the newer clanging features LTO will
work better with LD this is already in
the NDK as an experimental feature it
has been for a release or two now it's
still got some rough edges in the
indicate particularly on Windows it
doesn't always work we are always
working on this I believe
r21 will have most of those issues fixed
however other cases it does work like I
said we are using this for the OS so it
does work in a good number of cases if
you are not impacted by any of the
existing bugs and you do want your
builds to be faster it is worth a shot
if you do encounter bugs please file
them this is still quite early for us
which is why there is no solid roadmap
here normally we would say you know
we're going to make this a default in
this release and then remove it in this
release we haven't made it to that point
yet but please do try it out if you get
a chance a larger task here is making it
easier to access third-party libraries
in your NDK applications we want
something as simple as just apt install
open SSL dev if you've ever tried
building that for Android it is quite a
hassle it does not use any of our
supported build systems so you have to
make their build system work with the
NDK it can be a hassle so we are
investigating a number of options to
make this easier for you so you can just
specify this in your build.gradle my app
depends on curl something like that this
is really early for us right now if you
do have any suggestions or there's a use
case you think we're not going to
consider there is a bug it is linked
from our NDK github page please go leave
a comment there we'd love to hear from
you on that it is definitely not too
late for us to change our plans here so
yes help us help you try the OS betas
try the NDK betas sooner you file bugs
the more likely it is that we won't ship
them it is never fun when you find out
that the only thing you can do is work
around an existing bug because it is too
late to fix it
file bugs at our github bug tracker give
feedback if you even if you just have a
question to ask it's a good place to
start the worst thing that will happen
is I will close your bug with an answer
if you do have questions you want to
talk to us about in person we do have
office hours tomorrow morning at 8:30 if
you are anything like me and that sounds
terrible we will also be around at 2:00
in the afternoon and thank you for your
time
[Applause]
[Music]